you mentioned to me
that you have a lab in your home
and then i said that you're basically
rick from rick and morty which is
something i've been thinking this whole
conversation
and then you say
that there's a glowing pickle
that you used something involving cold
plasma i believe i don't know but can
you explain the glow and pickle
situation
[Laughter]
and is there many arbitrarily many
versions of you in alternate dimensions
so i think you're aware of i tried to
make an electrochemical
memory in at home
um using a and the only way using a
pickle the only way i could get any um
traction with it was actually by
plugging it into a very high voltage
alternating current and then putting in
a couple electrodes but my kids weren't
impressed they're not impressed with
anything i do any experiments i do at
home i think it's quite funny but you
connected your pickle to some electro i
mean 240 volts yeah ac yeah and then had
a couple of electrodes on it so what
happens is a pickle um
this is a classic thing you do
i mean i shouldn't pranks you do you put
a pluck pickle into the mains and just
leave it run away and leave it and what
happens is it it starts to decompose it
heats up and then explodes because the
water turns to steam and it just
violently explodes but i wondered if i
could cause the iron sodium potassium
ions in the pickle to migrate it'd been
in a in a jar right so being in a in a
brine
that was yeah that was not my that was
not my best experiment so i've done far
better experiments in my lab at home at
that time was a failed experiment but
you never know it could uh
every experiment is a successful
experiment uh if you stick with it long
enough well i mean i get i got kicked
out of my own lab by my research team
many years ago and for good reason i
mean my team is brilliant and i used to
go and just break things so what i do do
at home is i have a kind of electronics
workshop
um and i prototype experiments there
then i try and then i try and suggest to
my team sometimes maybe we can try this
thing
and they would just say oh well that's
not going to work because of this and
i'll say aha but actually i've tried and
here's some code and here's some
hardware can we have a go so that i'm
doing that less and less now as i get
even more busy but um that's quite fun
because then they feel that we're in the
you know in the experiment together
you